[Music]
homecoming is a 2018 Amazon original
show from the producers of mr. robot
starring Julia Roberts season one
follows Heidi Bergman who works as a
therapist in a facility that deals with
the rehabilitation of PTSD suffering
military personnel throughout this video
I'll be discussing the ending of
homecoming with points from show
director Sam as male in his interview
with her a-list there will be heavy
spoilers so it may be worth skipping
this video for now if you're yet to
watch the season with that out the way
I'm definition and I roon it so you
don't have to you homecoming takes place
over two time periods 2018 and 2022 most
viewers will instantly be hit by the
aesthetic presentation choices when
watching the future events as the screen
is cut down to a four by three ratio
this not only symbolizes that the
characters feel boxed in after the
events of homecoming but also adds
weight to things that have happened to
them the homecoming facility cured the
PTSD suffering soldiers by medicating
them to the point that they lost their
memories in order to rid them of trauma
with massive part of their lives missing
they are unable to fill in all the
details and have blank spots
hence did the box in the future that
they now live in throughout the show
highly gains an attachment to one of the
soldiers named Walter and this is season
Ones main focus when Heidi discovers
that he's being redeployed she doubles
his dosage in order to save him from the
trauma that he will likely face
Heidi is forced to leave Hong coming and
she manages to find other work though
she is unable to escape her past the
government come after her and question
her on what she remembers which is very
little she manages to track Walter down
and in the final episode of season one
the two meet and exchange a conversation
that on the surface seems like little
more than chitchat however when Walter
leaves Heidi notices that the four
at a table is askew Walter did this
before leaving and it's obviously a call
back to an earlier episode in that
office when Walter did the same thing
with a pen to me it really hammers home
the fact that he indeed still carries
the memories of homecoming but it's
lying low in order to avoid all
persecution that could potentially come
it's a really nice and hopeful moment
that lets us certainly know that Walter
still remembers Heidi and the rekindling
of their relationship is definitely an
avenue that I could see season two
traveling down in the post-credits scene
we see the character Audrey turn the
tables on Colin however she also seems
traumatized by the events that she has
been a part of and there's a real tie
caught on me to her performance nothing
more than background dressings
throughout the majority of the show she
really comes into her own here and
teases what could come down the line in
his interview with Thrillist
director Sam Ismail discussed her
casting and said I don't want to spoil
anything for season two but we knew that
the character was going to play a
critical role I think at the time I had
seen downsizing I think it just came out
and I was blown away by her performance
I just thought there was something about
her even though she's in the background
and not foregrounded as much you are
going to pay attention to her you're
going to keep your eye on her and that's
exactly what we wanted to do with the
character so we reached out to hung and
luckily for us she was into the
character and into the show that she
wanted to come on and do it obviously
the ending isn't cut and dry and Allah
is definitely open to interpretation but
we can surmise that Audrey will be
playing a huge part down the line and I
can't wait to see how her role comes to
fruition now that Heidi knows Walters
location and that he is safe she will
likely want to keep him from danger so I
can imagine her traveling home in order
to make sure that he is not persecuted
by the people tracking her all that
Heidi wanted was Walter's happiness and
it's evident that he's now living a
simple and peaceful life this is a great
way to end the show and it's a really
poignant moment that really stuck with
me no matter what the two can face they
shared a brief moment together
and it definitely hammers home just how
much Heidi cared for the character which
is something that the soldiers didn't
feel when coming back from conflict and
it's a really touching moment to end
season one on so what are your thoughts
on season one of homecoming how did you
interpret the final exchange between
walter and heidi and what did you take
from the show's post credit scene
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of the
haunting of hill house which will be
linked at the end of this one this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]